ليس من الصعب العثور على ماده الكافيين
فهي موجوده في القهوه والشاي وكذلك
الشوكولاته والمشروبات الغازيه وحتى في
بعض الادويه فالما المنشطه تجعلك تشعر
باليقظه
والطاقه يزيد من تدفق الدم الى العضلات
ويفتح رئتيك ويعزز الاداء ولكن عندما
تستهلك الكثير منها فمن الممكن ان تتسبب
بمشاكل صحيه خطيره فمعدل الاستهلاك اليومي
الذي يمكن للفرد تناوله ما بين 300 الى
400 ملغم من الماده المنشطه يوميا وهذا ما
يعادل ثلاثه الى اربعه اكواب من القهوه
لكن القلق في هذه الايام يتزايد لا سما مع
وجود الكثير من المنتجات التي تحتوي على
كميات كبيره من تلك الماده مثل مشروبات
الطاقه ومسحوق الكافيين الذي يحتوي على
كميات كبيره منها فعلى سبيل المثال حذرت
اداره الاغذيه والعقاقير الامريكيه من ان
تناول ملعقه صغيره من مسحوق الكافيين
يعادل شرب 25 كوبا من
القهوه عندما يتناولون ما يعتقدون انها
مجرد جرعه فهي في الحقيقه اكثر ب 10 و15
و2 مره مما هو متوقع واستهلاك اكثر من
1000 ملغرام من الكافيين يمكن ان يؤدي الى
بعض الاثار الجانبيه الخطيره مثل عدم
انتظام حراره الجسم والغثيان
والرعاش وكذلك الارق وحتى الو
في بعض الحالات لذا وجب الحذر فافضل طريقه
لتجنب جرعه زائده من ماده الكافيين هي
التحقق من مكونات المشروبات التي نتناولها
لتحديد الكميه المسموح
بها